is
i think
almost everybody in america agreed on
the idea of eventually leaving
afghanistan left right middle was a very
small percentage of people in america
that didn't want to
leave afghanistan and they wanted to
stay because they thought it would have
taken a long time to shift the mindset
of folks in afghanistan
where did we go wrong with the way we
left afghanistan recently
well the entire
strategy of the united states has
collapsed and i would say patrick that
they did not have any kind of an idea of
how soon the taliban is really going to
take over and that's where we begin now
nobody is saying that the united states
should not have gone out yes there's
been a larger consensus that yes there
needs to be an exit
let's face it united states was not in
kabul or in afghanistan or nation
building it was not there for
governments it was not there to in fact
have a democratically elected government
or have a conducive atmosphere for
elections to take place it was there to
fight the al-qaeda and perhaps the
larger nexus of the terror groups that
have their epicenter in afghanistan's
neighborhood in pakistan
so that's where the united states has
collapsed it is collapsed not just in
the understanding of the taliban on its
understanding of the pakistan of its
understanding of the ethnic groups and
their divide within afghanistan but also
how there is perhaps intra
you know united states collapse of
policy on afghanistan on pakistan and
this entire region i say this because
military on one hand is doing something
else the diplomats are doing entirely
different so they are trying to convince
the afghan people that their every step
is afghan-led is for the people of
afghanistan but to the contrary what
happens on ground is we see the same
brutality taliban in power
uh you know exactly what was happening
when the 9 11 attacks happened what we
see
uh patrick is again those gory visuals
you remember of that
you know aircraft of the air force at
the kabul airport
running away almost fleeing
uh you know the kabul hamid karzai
international airport and people trying
to escape imagine what would be going
through their minds that they're
climbing
uh the wings of that aircraft who just
escaped that land somehow and that is
where the u.s has completely collapsed
or shattered over the last two years
salman khalidza and you know us
diplomats kept saying that we have a
plan we have a strategy we know where we
are going we absolutely have an idea but
the reality now is what the history will
remember is the united states betrayed
every afghan that stood for democracy
that stood for progress that stood for
better ties with united states but they
felt completely abandoned so if you like
this sort of short club from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]